non lasciatevi distrarre da niente in
questo video ma me ne frego registro
così bella agenti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo
tornati sugli hunger games nel mondo
vi spiego allora per chi non lo
conoscesse ed è strano c'è questo sito
che difetti permette di generare gli
hunger games con dei personaggi a tua
scelta tra cui sono spacciati era da un
bel po che non lo facevo forse già anche
un anno addirittura riproviamoci per
questo episodio di anche games o
aggiunto ovviamente dei personaggi
dispetto ad altra volta
presentiamo alle squadre nel distretto 1
signora il signore abbiamo j ax e
cannavacciuolo new entry cannavacciuolo
che secondo me già con lui abbiamo perso
tutti compresa katniss distretto 2
cristiano ronaldo e cristiano malgioglio
voluto unire questi due cristiani che
fanno entrambe le stesse cose insomma
andiamo avanti distretto tre sabrina e
anima nel distretto 4 troviamo jacopo e
daniel che poi la foto era la stessa è
nata la divisa in due distretto numero 5
jason martin garics che non è una coppia
che c'entra molto
vabbè distretto numero 6 fedez marco
merino questa è una coppia che non
centra una sega distretto 7 papa vj e la
mia bella la mia bella non deve morire
quindi andiamo avanti stretto 8 ariana
grande e più rebuy nel distretto 9
troviamo giulia penna e pietro che si
faranno sicuramente valere ristretto 10
step misuri distretto 11 thomas e vegas
nel distretto 12 vita è che gli hunger
games abbiano inizio let's go pro ceed e
che la fortuna sia sempre dalla mia
speriamo partiamo ragazzi ovviamente
utilizzo la traduzione di google per
aiutarmi a tradurre le cose bene mentre
i tributi stanno se loro poi vi suona il
corno j ax corre nella cornucopia e si
nasconde se ritrova una borsa piena di
esplosivi prego di non morire il primo
turno il dio mio che gioco stiamo
trovato dispositivi cristiano malgioglio
colpisce la testa di selena con una
mazza prezzo di un cristiano niente e
quindi la mia selena è morta mi consolo
con cristiano katniss sfuggire la
cornucopia tommaso
perché mi ha prodotto thomas tommaso è
diventato mason fugge dalla corno
dispiace thomas è diventato tommaso che
adesso mi chiamo lorenz procedere è
morta sono selena fantastico e sono
rimasto da solo
cristiano malgioglio riceveva comunità
l'anno scorso sconosciuto e tutta
cristiano famiglie riceve cibo fresco da
uno sforzo sconosciuto meno male che
giovanni rana mi pensa mentre facile
giulia penna attese i tempi un'imboscata
katniss e la ucc e la uccise brava
giulia penn ha ucciso katniss che è
impossibile lo uccideva me vegas
sconfigge thomas che non è più tommaso
in una rissa ma risparmio alla sua vita
più di pesca ufficio e fede si in una
rissa ma risparmia la sua vita pita
viaggia verso l'alto in che senso sta
volando pita la sta succedendo
jason cerca di infilzare il pesce con un
tridente anima raccoglie i fiori vabbè
anime è diventato olimpi marina grande è
punteggiata da spine mentre raccoglieva
che procedere
chi è morto selena katniss e j ax sfiga
è morta selena subito io sono vivo
importante quello suri e cristiano
raccontano storie su se stessi l'un
l'altro dio mio vero immagino troppo
cristiani rischio vinto champions league
coppa del mondo e surreali ieri ho fatto
prova a non ridere challenge nuovo dead
e discorsi incredibile marco perino
diceva comunità giuseppe napoli ma tutti
acqua pulita so io bevo acqua sporca una
scusa
daniel chiede ad ariana grande di
ucciderlo lei rifiuta tenendo daniel
vivo si vede chi è l'uomo dei due si
vede un sacco pietro chiede aiuto al
figure cristiano malgioglio ricevono
esplosivo ma quanti sponsor cia
cristiano
il grande fratello è che gli invia
scooter fa vigili interroga la sua
sanità mentale beh non avevo dubbi ben
giorno 2 pavia e riceve un accetta da
uno stesso ho conosciuto vai lo chef
tony miracle blade si va a comandare
thomas cristiano ronaldo marco marino
imboscano senza successo martin garics
aver island e jason che invece li
uccidono quindi sono morti tom cristiano
e marco marino uccisi da regali sarà il
grande jazz
va bene sto perdendo tutti i miei amici
giulia penso resterà pietro fanno
irruzione nell'accampamento di
cannavacciuolo mentre stava cacciando
mai disturbare cannavacciolo mentre
cucina hoc acciaio cio esperienza
sabrina si tengono per una cosa sasha
non leggere non è vero ha detto lui non
è scemo e scemo sabrina cerca legna da
ardere di rugiada mollata li sabrina
vegas tenta di infilzare il pesce ce lo
vedo un sacco due colpi di cannone
possono essere ascoltati lontananza gli
a koper fedez e vediamo momenti come
siamo messi tutti allora la metà e sono
morti più o meno io sono vivo un
miracolo ariana grande a tre uccisioni o
anche jason martin garics complimenti
negata bene di avanti anima e familiari
raccontano storie su se stessi l'un
l'altro spero io gli abbia raccontato di
sabrina e sono un problema vita e giulia
penna minacciano un doppio suicidio
fallisce e muoiono
vabbè sabrina viene dall'esaurimento
cosa è successo cinque colpi di cannone
possono essere ascoltati in lontananza
ragazzi si accorciano le distanze per la
vittoria attenzione io ci credo ragazzi
assurdo terni singhiozzo jason deciso
dalla con copia pietro non può gestire
resistenza pietro non può gestire le
circostanze e si suicida
ottima prova di pietro mi ha emozionato
oggi dai e io non ho ammazzato nessuno
però storia andò in finale come quando
gioca forme se lo aveva visto di tre
l'arena diventa pesce e nessuno può
vedere nulla finale incredibile più ripa
e anima e fa vj assurdo sono arrivato in
finale regala mai successo credo nelle
mie vecchie registrazioni dai uno su tre
mannaia deve essere quella buona per una
volta anima chiede a filipe di ucciderlo
lui rifiuta mantenendo un anima viva ma
come ammazza lo siamo rimasti tra sei
pazzo siamo ammazzo ti ammazzo riceve
acqua pulita almeno baby e vinci mannaia
the anima fa una fionda fa visita uccide
più di piper le sue forniture uno contro
uno fa vj contro sasha raga finale
incredibile
ti prego è molto più di base rimasti
solo io e sasha sasha tipo di uccisioni
una favi javer su stage a ragazzi finale
incredibile 3 2 1 con dj a breve dalla
bevanda di anima
la scambia per se stessa no cosa sono
cevolo come vada veramente sono morto
per mio stesso tranello
porca mark come ha vinto sasha va bene
ragazzine che possiamo fare un altro
tentativo perché non mi è andata giù
come è finita proviamoci lei o io ho
preso una bottiglia di acqua uno
straccio benizio già ubriacarmi anima
rompe il naso di sabrina per un cestino
di pane mazza che coppia fia dada è
morto sono più di bava quindi sabrina
solo il naso rotto non è morta next
thomas è svegliato dagli incubi me
l'immagino si sveglia tutto sudato non
mi chiamo tommaso e poi attorno a
dormire origini 30 di accendere un fuoco
ma non ha successo figurati manca solo
trovare i bastoncini anima lancia un
coltello nella testa di cannavacciuolo e
anche cannavacciuolo cinque colpi di
cannone jacopo solo di cristiano ariana
grande ex novo cholo let's go per parigi
katniss selena attaccano con successo e
uccidono martin garics pita e anima
perfetto esattamente la rivincita che
volevo con sasha a posto ma bisogna
vincere per 4 colpi di cannone si
possono ascoltare in lontananza
j ax martin garics fitta e anima
visualizzato stato di tutti siamo più o
meno metà vivi metà morti io ho tre
killer selena 4 kg ammazzo cristiano
ronaldo tende alle finite di thomas
pietro sconfigge selena in combattimento
ma risparmio sua vita bravo pietro
perché sa restituito malissimo da parte
mia
selena pietro e sabrina i danni il dr
mona turni las vegas chiede a jason di
ucciderlo lui rifiuta mantenendo vegas
viva ma perché danno delle ragazze a
tutti che tenessero applica su un albero
tutti sti qua dormono a turni me
compreso un colpo di cannone può essere
sentite lontananza giulia penna che non
ha atteso le sue ferite purtroppo
attenzione attenzione sta schermata vedo
me e sabrina non so cosa succede spero
che sabrina non mi faccia di interi male
sabrina favini si incontrano e decidono
di fare tregua per la notte
in che senso pietro da fuoco anche lui e
lui lo sta proponendo il four si vede
proprio che dal foro bravo pietra dunque
non ci si ammazza più siamo tutti vivi
tutti gli effetti nessuno si ammazza più
daniel come molto non me lo sono perso
che pirla cristiano ronaldo abbatte
diverse volte la testa di vegas contro
una roccia ok giasone mangia
consapevolmente bacche tosti che già so
non ne ho e giasone bene qua che c'è
bravo giasone bravo bravo giasone
procedere selena tenta di arrampicarsi
su un albero ma accade su pietro
uccidendo entrambi
ok thomas mette un esplosivo fuori
uccidendo sabrina katniss decapita
cristiano ronaldo con una spada fede
scade in una fossa e muore e quindi
siamo rimasti un 1 2 3 e 4 cavolo mega
finale incredibile step riferisce
chiaramente che intenzionalmente la
mette fuori dalla sua infelicità cosa
madonna quanta gente da sei colpi di
cannone selena pietro sabrina cristiano
fedez katniss secono i vasti vivi in 123
step prima ci mentalmente fate tornare
una mina mentre cerca di armarla quindi
è morto fa vigili uccide toma sulla sua
stessa arma
signori signori il vincitore po vigente
del distretto set che briciole culo non
so come sia possibile ragazzina
seriamente ringrazio volevo ringraziare
tutte le persone mi sono sempre stato
accanto volevo ringraziare i miei
sponsor tra cui share toni giovanni rana
boh spero che video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi questa vittoria la dedico anche
un bacino questar hunger games sempre
bello di farlo perché mi dà un non so
che di gioia come solito ragazzi video
vicino al momento mi piace anche fare il
socio del comitato descrizione senza che
ci si schieri noi ci vediamo come sempre
hanno proseguito
[Musica]